Hmm.
When we talk about meaning in life,
it is a metaphor.
It means that our actions are oriented towards some greater purpose,
like the words in a sentence,
our range to point to some higher understanding.
We are meaning making creatures and we make sense of the world around us by
assigning it meaning how one finds meaning in life is often dependent on the
prevalent worldview in which they live.
Most of the dominant world views which have shaped our modern world had their
origin between the period of 800 to 300 BC known as the axial revolution.
It is called the axial age because it came with a radical turning point in how
humanity viewed its role in the cosmos.
Taking place in four main locations is real.
Greece,
India,
and China.
From 1200 to 1150 BC,
they experience the greatest collapse of civilization the world has ever seen,
much greater than the fall of Rome.
Within 50 years,
more cities,
political organizations and ways of life go out of existence than any time in
world history.
The Hittite,
Egyptian,
Canaan and Mycenaean Greek civilizations all face widespread destruction from
roughly 1150 to 800 the world enters a dark age,
huge amounts of literacy or lost trade breaks down and there is enormous
economic decline.
This collapses due to mini converging factors,
but the result was clear,
a violent sudden and culturally disruptive transition which shook the
preexisting worldview to its very core,
a worldview we are going to refer to as the continuous cosmos.
It was based on a belief that any difference between the natural human and
sacred worlds is only a difference in degree.
The gods acting in very human ways,
but simply possessed more power.
The chaos and violence you see in the world.
It's just a part of that world.
There is no difference between the violence of nature,
the violence of humans and the violence of the gods.
Secondly,
there was a belief that everything was cyclical like the days in the seasons.
You did not want to alter the world too drastically because it would inevitably
come back to affect you.
Wisdom in this old worldview meant the knowledge that was needed to gain the
most power and prosperity.
It was important to become as embedded in the world as you possibly can.
This was a powerful way to orient yourself and it built in sustained many of the
great civilizations of the past.
What happened is these old kingdoms passed away,
small states begin to emerge.
There is more experimentation with social and cultural organization.
New Cycle technologies are invented which have an enormous impact on our
cognition.
If a physical technology is designed to fit the way the human body operates to
expand our physical capabilities,
a psycho technology is designed to fit in,
enhance the capabilities of the mind.
The greatest of these psycho technologies was the emergence of alphabetic
literacy.
Old Forms of literacy were very difficult to learn often with thousands of
symbols standing for complex ideas.
It is likely that less than one percentage of the population was literate as it
was confined to a very small ruling elite with symbols.
Now standing for basic phonemes,
alphabetic literacy becomes much more accessible and it was during this period
that literacy was spread to a much greater percentage of the population.
As a technology literacy was able to stretch our cognition across much greater
spans of time.
Suddenly I could take my thoughts now,
my thoughts from a week in a month ago and apply them all to the same problem.
This allowed for the emergence of second order thinking that is a knowledge and
awareness of our own cognition.
As we began to empower and enrich the mind,
suddenly we become much more self critical and self aware.
This rise in our capabilities for self examination came hand in hand with the
rise in our ability for self deception.
Our mind and our perception acts as a lens through which we see the world.
An increased ability for self critical cognition comes with an increased ability
to distort reality.
The mind can twist itself out of alignment.
Misinterpreting in misperceiving the world around us,
I wear glasses which allow me to see the world much more clearly.
If the lens gets smudged,
it can distort my vision.
So what can I do when this happens?
I can take a step back and look at the glasses.
I can examine the medium of site itself.
I can determine what patterns are.
Properties are distorting my perception in order to fix them.
With the emergence of second order thinking and the ability to reflect on our
own cognition,
we can fix and transform the mind to see the world more clearly.
With this mode of thinking and new dominant worldview emerges,
we moved from a view of reality as a continuous cosmos which is cyclical and
only varies in degree to two completely separate worlds.
There is an everyday world be sent by self deception,
violence and suffering.
A world in which we constantly acting it's star,
individual and collective self interest.
A world filled with frustration,
futility and despair and there was a real world,
a world free from self deception free from the suffering and violence that we
cause a world in which we do not act in a self destructive manner and we can
flourish into fully realized human beings.
With this transition and worldview comes a change in the way we think of wisdom.
It is no longer to gain power and prestige in this world.
Wisdom is now seen as the ability to transcend this illusory world and awakened
to the world that is real.
We capture this idea in the metaphors that we use for transcendence,
metaphors of enlightenment,
waking up,
growing up,
being born again,
being woke a f is the kids are calling it now are all pointing towards moving
from this world of illusion to the world of reality.
The prevalence of this idea of waking up in pop culture points to how much this
world view still affects us to this day.
Remember that in this old view of reality,
you did not want to affect the world too drastically or would inevitably come
back around to affect you.
With this one shift in thinking,
we suddenly awakened to the fact that the future is wide open and that our
actions and moral choices,
heavy direct influence on how the cosmos unfolds.
What connects you right now to the seven year old version of yourself?
Every cell has died and been replaced so your body is not the same,
but we tell a story that runs like a thread into our past and connects us to who
we are now.
Narrative,
the idea of the beginning,
a middle and an end where some central problem is presented and then solve
through the actions of the protagonist is deeply rooted in who we are.
We simplify narrative down to it's most easily graspable for so we can practice
it over and over again.
We ask each other,
how was your day?
Tell me about yourself.
We want to hear each other's stories.
We Orient Ourselves in the world by understanding where we fit within the larger
narratives and Meta narratives that we hear and tell each other these stories
constitute what is real and significant.
In the pre axial age,
their sense of time was fragmented.
There were stories here and there,
but no overarching story for why time is unfolding in the way it is.
The idea of time and folding in a narrative fashion has its origin.
Once again in the axial revolution and perhaps the most unlikely of places.
There is a beginning in which humanity is cast out from paradise,
from this real world,
free from suffering and self deception.
Then a story unfolds of how this conflict is resolved and how humanity can
reclaim is standing and returned to the paradise that was lost.
Unlike many gods of the past,
the god of the Hebrews is not tied to any specific location,
but instead he seems to be a god of history.
He moves through time and space to deliver the Israelites from slavery in Egypt
into a promised land of milk and honey.
The fact that Egypt was chosen is deeply symbolic as it represents the epitome
of the pre axial world.
Instead of a belief in a cyclical cosmos,
the belief emerges that the future can be radically different from the past and
that our choices can bring about a better future.
Suddenly our human actions take on a cosmic significance.
Through our own moral action.
We can steer the universe towards a better or worse ending.
We can move from this land of self deception and self-destruction into a world
free from the pain and suffering that we on ourselves and each other.
Their faith and bringing this better world to fruition was not faith as it is
thought of now that is believing something without evidence.
Instead it was a sense of timing in how things were turning.
It was paying attention to the course of history in observing how history was
repeating itself.
Yeah.
To live in the right way,
the way in which we are the least susceptible to self deceptive in self
destructive behavior.
It means developing a sensitivity,
an understanding of these pivotal moments,
these turning points in history in which things can radically change for better
or worse.
Okay.
This idea took hold in the world of ancient Greece,
although in a very different form and together these ideas merged and formed the
pillars of Western thought for thousands of years after.
Thank you guys for watching.
I hope you stick around for future videos because I love making them and I love
sharing these ideas.
A lot of work and research goes into each video and if you liked the channel and
want to support us,
there are a few ways you can do that.
If you want a free audio book from audible,
we get a commission for each sign up.
If you are already planning on buying something from Amazon,
using our banner does help us out a lot.
Or we just launched our patrion page where you can get all kinds of rewards for
supporting us directly.
Either way,
I truly appreciate the support and I will see you guys next time.